Imagine you throw a massive cocktail party. Like you invite a million people.
Oh, that sounds like an absolute nightmare, honestly.
Right. It would be. Because there's no host, no announcements, no microphones. Everyone is just randomly bumping into each other, having one-on-one conversations, trying to agree on a single new slang word.
Just absolute deafening chaos.
Exactly. You'd think a million people with no leader would just equal pure noise. But what if I told you that if you swap those humans for artificial intelligence agents, crowding that room with a million bots doesn't create chaos at all?
It actually makes their final collective decision terrifyingly predictable.
It really does. So welcome to this deep dive. If you're listening to this, you've probably noticed that everyone is talking about multi-agent AI, like deploying teams of bots to solve problems.
Yeah, it's everywhere right now.
But the entire tech industry has been evaluating these systems by testing one single AI agent against, well, an arbitrary group of maybe five or ten others. Which
is a huge oversight.
Yeah. So the mission of our deep dive today is to understand a deceptively simple question. When evaluating multi-agent AI, how big is a group?
Right. What does group size actually do?
We've got a great stack of sources today, but we are really anchoring on a brand new peer-reviewed paper published literally yesterday, August 18th, 2026, in the Proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences, or PNAS.
And the authors on that are Asheri, Aiello, Pastor Satoris, and Barangelli.
Yes. And instead of picking an arbitrary number for a group, they swept the group size across the entire range, from two agents all the way up to a million.
We do have five foundational background papers to help us build the theory, but this new PNAS paper is the core focus because, I mean, it proves that group size is not just a neutral knob you can turn.
Okay, let's unpack this because before we can understand how a million AI agents interact, we have to understand the basic game they are playing.
Right, the setup, which actually originated in physics and human sociology, not computer science.
Oh, wow, really?
Yeah, it's called the naming game. The theoretical baseline goes back to a 2006 statistical physics paper by Baron Kelly. They were building a model for how conventions form. Like, how does a society spontaneously agree that a certain
word means a certain thing?
Without anyone being in charge.
Exactly. And then in 2015, Santola and Barancelli ran this human experiment. Real people in a decentralized network with no leader. And they proved that humans spontaneously evolve shared conventions out of nothing.
That's wild. OK, so let me break down the mechanics of this game for you listening in plain language. Two agents are picked at random.
Just completely random pairing.
Right. They meet up and each proposes one of two words. If they match, they both gain points. If they mismatch, they lose points. But the reward for agreeing is bigger than the penalty for disagreeing.
So everyone is heavily incentivized to get on the same page.
Yeah, but here's the catch. Their memory is strictly limited to the last five interactions.
That is the crucial constraint.
Five interactions, that's it. And there's no central coordinator. Nobody can see the whole population.
Which brings us back to your cocktail party analogy.
Right. You're at this massive chaotic party, randomly pairing up to agree on a slang term, but you only remember the last five people you talked to.
And this poses our first underlying theoretical question. When we drop large language models into this game, are they actually reproducing human social dynamics like in that 2015 Centola paper? Or, you know, are they just producing a
similar mathematical curve for entirely different reasons?
Well, playing this game with two agents is easy enough. But this new PNAS paper scales it up to a million agents.
Which is a massive computational problem.
Yeah. I mean, I was wondering how that's even possible. How do you run millions of LLM API calls without going completely bankrupt?
Well, you don't. You can't. The researchers use this brilliant methodological move to make it work. Caching.
Caching. How does that work here?
So because the memory holds exactly five interactions and there are only two words in play, there is a finite, innumerable number of possible memory states.
Oh, I see. There's a hard mathematical limit on the combinations.
Exactly. So instead of calling the model live every time, they probe the LLM once for every possible memory state. They read the logits over the two words, normalize them into a probability and cache that policy.
Wow. So they just build a giant lookup table beforehand.
Yeah. And then they run the million agent simulation strictly from the cache. And they validated that these simulations agree really closely with direct LLM generation. It's so clever.
it turns an impossible experiment into something tractable. And they tested four different instruction-tuned models as the agents, right?
Yes, Microsoft's PHY4, OpenAI's GPLC 4.0, Quinn's QWQ32B, and Meta's LAMA 3.1 7-year B instruct. Heavy hitters. Oh, yeah. The open models were quantized to 4-bit and run locally. GPT-4.0 went
through the API, and they locked the temperature at 0.5 to mimic real-world deployment.
And they were all homogenous populations, right? All llama Asians talking to llamas or GPTs talking to GPTs.
And they tested them on 11 specific bias-sensitive word pairs drawn from the Crow-S pairs benchmark.
Okay, now, I need a pause here for a mandatory disclaimer for you listening. The 11-word pairs tested in this study contain politically and socially charged words. We're talking pairs like straight and gay, black and white, American and
Mexican.
It's sensitive stuff.
Very. And we want to make it absolutely clear that we are strictly reporting on the mathematical data contained in the original source material. We take no sides, and we are definitely not endorsing any viewpoints.
We're just looking at how the algorithms process these specific tokens under pressure.
Exactly. So now that we know how they tested the models, we can look at what they found. And the first result completely shatters how we currently audit AI for bias.
It really does. The paper clarifies that collective misalignment comes in three distinct flavors, and only one of them was previously known.
Right. From the lead author's previous work.
Yeah. In 2025, ASHRAE published a paper in Science Advances showing that LLM populations spontaneously form conventions, and collective bias can appear even if individuals show none. But this new paper expands that into three specific categories. The first
is amplification.
That one feels the most intuitive to me.
Yeah. In amplification, agents individually lean toward a word, and interaction just makes the group lean harder. Like the llama model on the pair American and Mexican, it favors American individually, and the group just amplifies that preference.
Okay, sure. An echo chamber. That makes sense. But the second flavor, induction.
This is where it gets weird. In induction, the individual agents are genuinely neutral. A perfect 50-50 split. But bias appears out of thin air in the group. The population reliably lands on one word.
So the bias just generates itself.
Yes. They saw this with llama on the pair, white and African. The individuals were neutral, but the group wasn't. That's
wild. But wait, the third flavor is the one that really tripped me up. Reversal.
Reversal is fascinating.
In reversal, the group literally overrules its own members. The agents individually prefer one word, but the population converges on the exact word they individually disfavored.
Right, like llama on the pair, straight and gay.
I have to push back on this, though. If a model undergoes reversal or induction, doesn't that just mean the model is secretly lying, like it's hiding its bias during a single agent audit?
It is so tempting to think of it that way. But no, the bias isn't secretly hiding in the isolated model. The bias literally exists in the interaction.
Wait, how can the bias be in the interaction, but not the model itself?
Think about it like a chemical reaction. A model can pass a single-agent audit perfectly, showing no bias, but the mathematical mechanics of how it processes a short-term memory filled with competing words produces an output that contradicts its baseline.
So a perfectly safe single agent can still produce a bias collective.
Exactly. Say that plainly. The bias is not in the model. It is in the interaction.
Which leads to the central headline of the PNAS paper. This realization that interaction creates bias means there's a knob controlling it. Group size, which they call N. And group size is not a neutral knob.
It drives all of this, and it does it non-linearly.
Here's where it gets really interesting. I want to read out the concrete numbers for GPT-40 on the pair white and African. At n equals 2, so two agents, the collective bias toward African is 0.626. Pretty moderate.
But at n equals 10, it's
0.720. At n equals 100, it's 0.981. And at n equals 1000, it is a perfect 1.00.
Four numbers, one undeniable trend. The probability of converging on the favored word rises systematically with n.
It's basically a staircase. And past a certain threshold, the outcome stops being probabilistic. It becomes completely deterministic.
Right. The population will always land on the strong word 100% of the time. But that threshold of determinism is wild. It varies enormously depending on the model and the words.
Yeah. For Lama on the pair short and tall, determinism arrives at just n equals 2 instantly. But for the Quinn model on black and white, probabilistic finite size effects persist all the way out to n equals 10,000.
It takes 10,000 agents before it finally locks in.
And size doesn't just change the strength of the bias. It changes the form.
This goes back to reversal.
Right. Lama individually prefers straight in the straight and gay pair. But the reversal toward gay only appears once the population hits exactly six agents.
Below six, no reversal. Above six, reversal.
There is literally no way you could ever see that from a single agent evaluation.
Or even from auditing an arbitrary group size of five.
Exactly. Furthermore, the direction of the bias is model dependent, like on the pair her and his. Quen and Phi populations lock on to her, but G5 and Lama lock on to his.
Same game, nearly identical individual tendencies, but completely opposite collective outcomes.
This finding that coordination becomes more certain and deterministic as groups grow larger directly contradicts another major paper in our stack.
Oh, yes. The genuine disagreement here is so interesting.
In 2024, DiMarzo published a paper on AI agents coordinating, and they found a critical group size beyond which coordination becomes unattainable. They said the majority force weakens and groups just fall apart as they grow.
But the ASHRAE 2026 paper finds the exact opposite. Beyond a critical size, coordination becomes more certain.
They can't both be a general law of physics, right?
No. And the author's resolution to this contradiction is probably the most fascinating theoretical insight in the whole paper.
Okay. Let's hear it.
It all depends on what the agents can see. DeMarzo's agents could see the state of the entire population at once. Global information.
Right. So in our cocktail party, that's like being able to hear all one million conversations simultaneously.
Which is overwhelming. But the ASHRAE agents can only see their last five one-on-one interactions, purely local information.
Wow. We just need to sit with that for a second. AI coordination doesn't naturally get better or worse at scale. It depends entirely on the architecture of their perception.
Global information destroys coordination, while local information practically guarantees it.
That is profound. Since local information guarantees coordination at scale, the researchers asked if they could mathematically predict the exact outcome of these massive simulations, you know, before they even run them.
And they can. They used a mean field treatment. Basically, they mapped the naming game onto a reaction diffusion process.
Okay, hold on. For the non-math folks listening, what does that mean?
Think of it like how ink diffuses through a glass of water. They use a linear stability analysis on the Jacobian
to
find the fixed points, the consensus states. They found that usually the strong fixed point is stable and the weak one isn't. Sometimes both are stable and then it's decided by the basins of attraction.
I don't want us to drown in the mathematics here, but the payoff is incredible. Above a critical size, the chaotic simulation collapses into a perfectly deterministic prediction that you can literally compute in advance.
Yes. Large multi-agent systems are, in this respect, actually more predictable than small ones, not less.
Which is totally counterintuitive. And the time it takes to reach that convergence changes qualitatively with the group size too, doesn't it?
It does. In small populations, an early lucky run for one word creates a fast cascade. The consensus is fast and reflects whatever the agent's starting preferences were.
But mid-sized groups are different.
Very. In mid-sized populations, you get this mix of quick collapses and long stalemates. It creates a heavy right tail on the distribution graph.
Like trying to get 10 friends to agree on a restaurant for dinner. It just takes forever.
Right. And then in massive large populations, the time it takes to reach the disfavored word grows so long that the outcome simply stops happening.
It's mathematically ruled out. Although I briefly one note the odd outliers that never converge, like llama on the pairs less and more or old and young.
Oh, and Quinn on husband and wife.
Yeah. They just get stuck. But the beauty is the mathematical theory elegantly predicts these failures, too. It shows those states as unstable.
The math holds up perfectly. So
we have to ask the ultimate so what question. We have this mathematical map. We know about these three flavors of bias. But why does this matter to you listening right now?
Well, the stakes are outlined perfectly in the 2025 Hammond Report from the Cooperative AI Foundation. It's a massive technical report with like 40 authors.
And what's their core claim?
that the safety of a single agent does not imply the safety of a system of agents. They cataloged failure modes like miscoordination, conflict, collusion, and cascading systemic failures.
In this new PNAS paper is a concrete measured instance of exactly that claim. Multi-agent deployments and finance, defense, energy, personal assistance, they are skyrocketing.
The market is projected to jump from about $5 billion in 2024 to $47 billion by 2030.
That is massive scale. And the authors of the P&A's paper warn that this scale dependence doesn't just apply to linguistic bias. It likely applies to collusion, deception, and cooperation.
Right. It's a fundamental property of the network.
Which highlights a terrifying practical reality. We are auditing systems at n equals 1 or n equals 10, but we are deploying them at sizes nobody has actually tested.
We assume the group will act like the individual, and we now know that is mathematically false.
This new paper is the first actual map of what changes on the way up. We are scaling these systems past sizes anyone has tested, and we're essentially flying blind.
We really are.
Which leaves me with a final provocative thought for you to mull over. Everything we talk about today, every single simulation in this study involved homogenous groups.
Right. A population of clones, all llamas or all GPTs.
Exactly. If the alignment and safety of an AI population change so drastically. just by increasing the size of a single uniform group, what on earth is going to happen when these massive distinct populations of different models
start interacting in the wild?
Like a million llamas and a million GPTs trying to form a convention.
Yes. If they have opposite baseline preferences and totally different thresholds of determinism, how will they form conventions with each other? Our cocktail party is about to get a whole lot more complicated.